[Music]
a few years ago
when my laboratory got interested in
studying stress in humans
we asked ourselves what are the patterns
of breathing that allow for the most
rapid reduction in stress levels and
more importantly what are the patterns
of breathing that can be done in real
time
so that people can adjust their stress
while they're still engaging in life
right breath work classes running off to
excellent for a weekend is a magical
experience but life demands pressing on
you that's typically when you feel
stressed so it is still true that
vacation long meditation retreats and
massages or a nice drink if you're of
drinking age still work but they're slow
and they take you offline
the physiological side is a pattern of
breathing that was actually discovered
by physiologists in the 30s
and that was essentially rediscovered by
professor jack feldman at ucla a world
expert in the neurobiology of
respiration and by my colleague mark
krasnow at stanford who studies lung
function
the physiological side is a pattern of
breathing that we all engage in
in deep sleep when levels of carbon
dioxide in our bloodstream get too high
we or our dogs you can see your dog do
this we'll do a double inhale followed
by an extended exhale
children or or adults for that matter
that are sobbing and lose their breath
so to speak we'll also do a double
inhale exhale that's the spontaneous
execution of what we call the
physiological psi the reason it works so
well to relax us
is because it offloads a lot of carbon
dioxide all at once and the way it works
is the following our lungs are not just
two big bags of air
we have all these little millions of
sacks of air that if we were to lay them
out flat they would be as big as about a
tennis court or so the volume of air
therefore and the volume of carbon
dioxide that we can offload is
tremendously high except that we get
stressed as carbon dioxide builds up on
our bloodstream and is kind of a double
whammy these little sacs deflate now
when we do a double inhale so i'll do
this now twice through my nose or you
could do this or you could do it through
your mouth but it works best for your
nose it's inhale
and then you sneak a little bit more air
in at the very end when you do that you
re-inflate those little sacs and when
you exhale
then you
discard all the carbon dioxide at once
so the simple way to describe this
protocol is that
unless you are under water
you do a double inhale
followed by an extended exhale and you
offload the maximum amount of carbon
dioxide and we found in our laboratory
and other laboratories have found that
just one
two or three of those physiological size
brings your level of stress down very
very fast
and it's a tool that you know you can
use anytime i do hope that people kind
of watch other people or dogs as they
start to relax or go down to sleep
you'll see this pattern of breathing but
again it can be consciously driven
the other thing about breathing and the
reason why exhales are so vital is the
following
i know there's a lot of interest
nowadays in heart rate variability
well
most people don't realize this but your
breathing is actually driving heart rate
variability so when you inhale this dome
shaped muscle beneath your lungs your
diaphragm actually moves down because
the lungs expand it moves down when you
do that you create more space in the
thoracic cavity and you actually the
heart gets a little bigger it actually
expands
as a consequence blood flows more slowly
through that larger volume and the brain
quickly sends a signal down to the heart
to speed the heart up the short simple
version of this is inhales speed the
heart up
when you exhale the opposite is true
that dome-shaped muscle the diaphragm
moves up
the space in your thoracic cavity gets a
little bit smaller the heart gets a
little bit smaller blood
moves more quickly through that small
volume and the brain sends a signal to
the heart to slow the heart down
physicians know this as respiratory
sinus arrhythmia but this is the basis
of what we call hrv heart rate
variability and the simple way to
remember this is anytime you emphasize
exhales in other words making them
longer than your inhales
you are slowing the heart rate down
you're calming your system anytime you
emphasize inhales you make them more
vigorous or longer than your exhales
you're speeding up your heart
you